as we mentioned earlier President Trump
said today he wouldn't be willing to
answer questions from special counsel
Bob Muller but Trump's a longtime
confidant and former advisor Roger stone
says it is a trap
Roger joins us from Fort Lauderdale to
explain Roger I bet you loved hearing
the president just rift today about oh
yeah no problem I'll come and have a cup
of coffee unload my burdens well how
could this possibly be a trap Roger if
Mulder wants the best for the president
well look it's understandable why the
president is confident he knows he's
done nothing wrong but a first-year law
student would tell you that this is an
obvious perjury trap that the Robert
Mueller is taking advantage of the
president's loquacious nest the fact
that he's never a man who suffers from a
paucity of words and what is absolutely
clear is that mr. Muller has no evidence
of Russian collusion so now we're all
the way cycled back around to the
dismissal of mr. Comey and he seeks to
entrap the president in some kind of
process crime perjury or obstruction
therefore the best advice that I could
give the president and I agree with
Judge Andrew Napolitano on this is that
under no circumstances should he grant
mr. Mueller an interview it's a it's a
suicide mission it's a very clear
perjury trap under Lawrence Walsh's
investigation during iran-contra Roger
the special counsel there Walsh
agreed not to interview President Reagan
in person they submitted interrogatories
the president responded to the written
interrogatories and that's how it went
down
obviously here that with the precedent
of the Star Special Counsel they had the
videotaped testimony and so forth so
it's kind of a different precedent but
what if they agree to a narrow you know
a narrow pathway a narrow parameter
where you were only going to ask about
these two things that's what it in a
normal grand jury setting or a normal
interview setting for a normal client no
lawyer would allow you to go in they
would say okay we're only going
well it'll talk but only about these two
topics what about narrowing the confines
of the question well traditionally if
the information can be got otherwise the
president would not be interviewed a
perfectly reasonable compromise to avoid
a constitutional crisis would be for mr.
Muller to submit written questions and
for the president to respond to them in
writing I don't see how any reasonable
person could disagree with that but for
the president to walk into the the blade
as it were and to try to pretend that
Muller and his band of partisan pirates
are just honest brokers honest
prosecutors just trying to ferret out
the truth is disproved by everything we
know so far and now with an
extraordinary number of text messages
from the FBI going missing I'm old
enough to remember when 18 and a half
minutes of Nixon's White House tapes
went missing and the mainstream media
and the Liberals went insane where is
that outrage today if nothing that
proves the partisan nature of this
inquiry and the fact that the Department
of Justice under Rod Rosenstein who I've
advocated the president fire immediately
for his conflict of interest is not on
the level John you said earlier today
the following about what the president
should do and how we should consider it
let's watch I actually think President
Trump should welcome the opportunity to
speak to Muller and try to accelerate it
because after he's done that we'll wrap
up
Muller's probe Raj I assume you disagree
with that well spoken like the neocon
Bush I that he is look I think that's a
naive and I think that's how the
president's lawyers are selling this to
the president but these are the same
lawyers who urged him to waive executive
privilege and turn over all records
depending on the reality in the lack of
bias a right of Robert Mueller it is a
foolhardy piece of advice it is a
suicide mission under no circumstances
should the president grant Mueller a
live interview
clearly there is a compromise let them
submit questions in writing president
respond in having I think he could have
done better than Ty Cobb and John doubt
I mean God bless them as lawyers I mean
he needed his own dream team and I think
they made it to raise the bar for the
council representation as well Roger
thank you so much